do you think that physics is needed to
understand human consciousness or you
think that's possible it should describe
consciousness default of his core
knowledge of nature okay good your
question so physics so far cannot
clearly describe the human consciousness
so the biologies the mathematician begin
to understand some mechanism of the
treatment of information by the brain
how the information is transferred from
neuron to neuron cause the synapse but
this is just the beginning the first
tape and understanding the human
consciousness is very very far it's very
difficult to imagine that we can in the
next century understand he lay the this
is potential of the brain and now even
the physicists are beginning to
kai to develop a new type of computing
science which is called based on
neuromorphic electronics that is on
components that in contrast to the
competence of the computer of today
components that will have the synaptic
plasticity of the synapse the potential
of evolving as a function of the
information they have treated and so
this will give maybe a to rise to a new
generation of computer with an operation
closer to the operation to the mechanism
of the human brain but we are very very
far and from the fabrications or a
computer having the potential of the
human brain